Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. And there were in the same country shepherds abiding in the field, keeping watch over their flock by night. And lo, the angel of the Lord came upon them, and the glory of the Lord shone round about them, and they were sore afraid. And the angel said unto them, Fear not, for behold, I bring you good tidings of great joy, which shall be to all people. For unto you is born this day in the city of David, a Saviour, which is Christ the Lord. And this shall be a sign unto you, you shall find the babe wrapped in swaddling clothes, lying in a manger. And suddenly there was with the angel a multitude of the heavenly host,
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告版本、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在伯利恒之野地里有牧羊人夜间看守羊群。有主的使者站在他们旁边，主的荣光四面照着他们，牧羊人就甚惧怕。那天使对他们说：“不要惧怕！我报给你们大喜的信息，是关乎万民的；因今天在大卫的城里，为你们生了救主，就是主基督。你们要看见一个婴孩，包着布，卧在马槽里，那就是记号了。”忽然，有一大队天兵同那天使赞美神说：
praising God and saying, glory to God in the highest, and on earth, peace, goodwill towards men. Tom, that must be one of the most famous scenes in all human culture. It is, of course, the nativity, the shepherds having their vision and going in and gathering around the manger where the baby Jesus lies. I mean, it's the scene that you see every year. And certainly in Britain, in almost, I would guess, almost every primary school, certainly used to be in almost every primary school as children reenacted it. And all over the world, you see images of that. And we are now going, having set the scene in our previous podcast, we are going to try to reconstruct as best we can as historians, as skeptical historians, I suppose it's fair to say, the life of Jesus, aren't we? So we think he existed.
“在至高之处荣耀归与神！在地上平安喜悦归与人！”汤姆，这一定是人类文化中最著名的场景之一。这当然就是耶稣降生，牧羊人们看到异象，前去聚集在婴儿耶稣躺卧的马槽周围。我的意思是，这是你每年都能看到的场景。在英国，我敢说几乎在每一所小学里，过去肯定也几乎在每一所小学里，孩子们都会重现这一幕，全世界各地你都能看到这种形象。既然我们在上一期播客中已经设定了背景，现在我们要作为一个历史学家——我想可以说是持怀疑态度的历史学家——尽我们所能去重建耶稣的一生，不是吗？所以我们认为他是存在的。
We definitely think Jesus existed. You established that in the previous episode, all these references, the Roman references and so on. So on that question, did he exist or not? I think when you read the Gospels, you have the definite sense of a remarkable teacher. So simply on the basis of the parables that he tells, the stories, they are the most memorable stories ever written. They are incredibly powerful and effective. His teachings are, you know, they stick in the mind. And so the question is, well, where did these teachings come from? If there is no historical Jesus, if there is no person that they derive from, then we have to assume that
我们绝对认为耶稣存在。你在上一集里已经确定了这一点，所有这些记载，罗马人的记载等等。所以在“他是否存在”这个问题上，我想当你阅读《福音书》时，你会有种强烈的印象：这是一个非凡的老师。仅凭他所讲的比喻和故事来看，它们是有史以来最令人难忘的故事。它们极其有力且有效。他的教诲，你知道的，让人印象深刻。所以问题是，这些教诲从何而来？如果没有历史上的耶稣，如果没有一个人物作为这些教诲的来源，那么我们就必须假设，
basically they emerged from kind of assorted traditions that they were put together by the gospel writers. And if you think about, you know, you tell a writer, you've got to come up with a figure who in 2000 years time will be seen by millions and millions of people across the entire world as both human and divine, and he will have been seen as such for 2000 years, that would be a tough ask. It would, especially if you're getting a committee to do it. Oh my God. Yeah, exactly. You get four people doing it. So it seems to me that that is a much more improbable explanation that it was just made up than the fact that it does derive from someone extraordinary. And also the fact that he is an extraordinary figure is what explains why he comes to be seen as as what he was right so to
基本上它们是从各种流传的传统中浮现出来的，是由福音书的作者们拼凑在一起的。如果你想一想，你告诉一个作家：你必须塑造一个这样的人物——在两千年后，全世界千千万万的人会认为他既是人又是神，而且两千年来人们一直这样看他——这会是一个艰巨的要求。确实如此，特别是如果你让一个委员会来做这件事。天哪。没错，确实如此。你让四个人来做。所以在我看来，比起这些故事源自某位非凡人物的事实，这种说法（即故事纯属虚构）是一个更不可能的解释。而且，正因为他是一个非凡的人物，才能解释他为什么最终会被视为那样的人。所以从
that extent i'm not skeptical however there are obviously aspects of the story that i am skeptical about uh and and i think pretty much anyone familiar with uh you know the the basic details would be skeptical about and very very sadly and i hate to play you know scrooge and the grinch rolled into one but i think all the christmas stuff is is most unlikely to be true okay this is very poor this is very poor tom and very disappointing so we began the last podcast with the decree from caesar augustusus, Joseph going from Nazareth to Bethlehem with his wife, Mary, who is pregnant, and they can't get room at the inn, and they go to presumably a cattle shed or something like that. And Jesus is born and lies in the manger, where he is later inspected
这个角度来看，我并不怀疑。然而，显然故事中也有一些我感到怀疑的方面，呃，我想任何熟悉这些基本细节的人都会产生怀疑。而且非常非常遗憾的是，我讨厌扮演同时集吝啬鬼和圣诞怪杰于一身的角色，但我认为所有关于圣诞节的细节都不太可能是真的。好吧，这太糟糕了，汤姆，这太令人失望了。所以在上一期播客的开头，我们提到了奥古斯都皇帝的政令，约瑟夫带着怀孕的妻子玛利亚从拿撒勒前往伯利恒，他们在客栈里找不到房间，于是去了大概是牛棚之类的地方。耶稣出生了，躺在马槽里，后来被
by assorted shepherds, wise men, and so on. And you don't believe this happened. So there are all kinds of problems with it. One of which anyone who listened to the previous episode will immediately have picked up on, which is that Jesus was not a Roman subject. And so his father living in Nazareth did not have to pay taxes. The other problem is that Joseph is having to travel to Bethlehem because that's where King David was born. He's descended from King David. The idea that the Romans would care about the line of descent from someone who'd lived centuries and centuries before is insane. Yeah. I mean, surely everybody would have to be on the move saying, where was my ancestor born? I must go to that place immediately. Absolutely. So that doesn't make sense at all.
形形色色的牧羊人、东方三博士等人探视。而你不相信这一切发生过。这里面存在着各种各样的问题。其中之一，任何听过上一集的人都会立刻注意到，那就是耶稣并不是罗马臣民。因此，他住在拿撒勒的父亲并不需要纳税。另一个问题是，约瑟夫不得不前往伯利恒，因为那是大卫王出生的地方。他是大卫王的后代。罗马人会关心一个几个世纪前生活过的人的后代血统，这种想法简直太疯狂了。是的。我的意思是，毫无疑问，每个人都必须四处奔走，说：“我的祖先是在哪里出生的？我必须立刻去那个地方。”完全正确。所以这根本讲不通。
And so you have to say, well, where has this story come from? And the basic thing is, is that biblical prophecy says that Bethlehem is where the Messiah will be born. And so therefore Jesus has to be got to Bethlehem. And essentially it seems as basic as that. There are further problems with the whole, you know, because our understanding of the Christmas narrative, it's a pooling of the two gospel accounts of Luke and Matthew, but they don't correspond. So when is Jesus being born? We're told in one account that the wise men come to Herod's court. Herod is anxious that a king of the Jews has been born in Bethlehem, and so launches the massacre of the innocents. But Herod dies in 4 bc we're also told that this census is being organized by corineus the
因此你不得不问：这个故事到底是从哪儿来的？最基本的原因是，圣经预言说伯利恒是弥赛亚诞生的地方。因此，耶稣必须被安排到伯利恒去。本质上，事情似乎就是这么简单。整个故事还存在其他问题，（你知道的，）因为我们对圣诞节叙事的理解，实际上是对路加和马太两部福音书记载的综合，但这两部福音书并不吻合。那么耶稣究竟是什么时候出生的？我们在一个记载中得知，东方三博士来到了希律王的宫廷。希律王担心一个犹太人的王在伯利恒出生，于是发起了屠杀无辜婴儿的行动。但希律王死于公元前4年。我们又被告知，这次人口普查是由叙利亚总督
governor of syria but corineus is doing this in ad8 so it's absolutely impossible 12 years yeah to square them however what is in i mean what is interesting about luke's treatment of this is that it echoes josephus Because this isn't the only time that Luke mentions the census. In Acts, which describes how the apostles after Jesus' death spread the gospel across the Mediterranean world, there is a Judean elder called Gamaliel who is advising other members of the council not to persecute the Christians. And he does this with reference to a rebel called Judas the Galilean, who in Luke's account, Gamaliel says, arose in the days of the census and inspired rebellion in the people who followed him.
居里扭（Quirinius）组织的，但居里扭是在公元6年或7年才进行这件事的，所以这完全是不可能的。相差了12年，是的，根本无法调和。然而，路加对这件事的处理有趣之处在于，它呼应了约瑟夫斯。因为这并不是路加唯一一次提到人口普查。在《使徒行传》中，它描述了耶稣死后使徒们如何在环地中海世界传播福音，其中有一个名叫迦玛列的犹太长老，他劝告议会的其他成员不要迫害基督徒。他提到了一位名叫加利利的犹大（Judas the Galilean）的叛军，路加记载迦玛列说，他是在人口普查的日子里出现，并激起了追随者的叛乱。
And this you also get in Josephus, that the census that is introduced when the Romans take over the province of Judea prompts this rebellion by this guy called Judas the Galilean. So there is a kind of nexus there of, I guess for Luke, even though Jesus isn't subject to Rome, the whole story is kind of illustrating what you also get in Josephus, the way in which this is an intrusive imposition by an imperial power. And of course, that then amplifies the contrast with the king of heaven being born in a stable. Right. So I think that's the dynamic that's going on there. This is a Christmassy podcast. Let's look at some of the Christmassy elements to that story.
这在约瑟夫斯的著作中也能找到：罗马人接管犹太省时引入的人口普查，引发了这个名叫加利利的犹大的叛乱。所以这里存在着某种联系，我想对路加来说，尽管耶稣不是罗马臣民，但整个故事某种程度上说明了你在约瑟夫斯著作中也能看到的情况——这是帝国强权的一种入侵式强加。当然，这反而在鲜明对比中放大了这位生于马槽的天国君王。没错，所以我觉得这就是其中运作的动态。这是一期充满圣诞气氛的播客。让我们来看看这个故事中一些具有圣诞气氛的元素吧。
I know we've got lots to get through, so we don't want to get completely bogged down. But is Jesus born in Bethlehemlehem yes or no do you think no he's born in nazareth he's clearly born in nazareth he's jesus of nazareth okay so no manger no stable you don't think that's plausible i mean where are those details from uh so the the reference to the cattle you know gazing down at the baby in the manger i think it's 10th century i think it's as late as that but it again it derives from um from biblical prophecy uh and so this is this is again is part of the challenge of deciding how historically accurate details within the gospels are because they're retrofitting to match prophecies now this doesn't necessarily you know if you know, if you get Jesus doing something that's in accordance with biblical prophecy, this doesn't necessarily mean that it didn't happen,
我知道我们要讲的东西很多，所以我们不想完全陷入其中。但是耶稣是生在伯利恒吗？是的还是不是？你觉得呢？不是，他生在拿撒勒，他显然生在拿撒勒，他是拿撒勒人耶稣。好吧，所以没有马槽，没有牛棚，你觉得那不可信？我的意思是，这些细节是从哪里来的？呃，关于牛（你知道的）注视着马槽里的婴儿的记载，我认为是在10世纪，我觉得一直到那么晚才有。但它同样源自圣经预言，所以这也是决定福音书中的细节在历史上有多少准确性的挑战的一部分，因为它们是为了迎合预言而被反向修正的。现在，这并不一定意味着（你知道，
because Jesus has agency. So when he goes into Jerusalem before his arrest, he famously goes in on a donkey. And this echoes a passage in Zechariah where it's foretold that the Messiah will do this. So it's perfectly possible to think that Jesus is aware of this and is kind of acting out a role, which seems much likelier. And also, I think that just because events get kind of biblicized, if you want to put it that way, they are described by the gospel writers with allusions to prophecy. Again, it doesn't mean that it didn't happen because that is what the gospel writers would do. But I think in this case, it's pretty clear that it didn't happen. And again, this does not disprove the existence of Jesus, the fact that there are miraculous stories that are told about his birth. Because Augustus, in Suetonius' biography of him, you get an almost identical description.
如果你发现耶稣做的事符合圣经预言，这并不一定意味着它没有发生过），
Suetonius describes it's narrated by a freedman of Augustus called Julius Marathas, who some have thought might have come from the region of Palestine or Syria, that a prodigy alerted everyone in Rome to the fact that nature was in labor with a child who would come to reign as a king over the Roman people. The Senate, thrown into panic, duly voted that no one born that year should be allowed to live. So, you know, that's very like Herod. So there's a definite element of a formula there, isn't there? Yeah, I think, you know, again, I think this is what's interesting is that the whole Christmas tradition, the whole story is, it's absolutely coming from the inheritance of Judean scripture,
因为耶稣有他的自主性。所以当他在被捕前进入耶路撒冷时，他骑着驴进去，这是出了名的。这呼应了《撒迦利亚书》中的一段话，其中预言弥赛亚会这样做。所以完全有可能的情况是，耶稣意识到了这一点，并且在扮演一个角色，这看起来要合理得多。而且我认为，仅仅因为事件被赋予了“圣经化”的色彩（如果你想这么说的话），即福音书作者用对预言的暗示来描述它们，这同样不意味着它没有发生过，因为这就是福音书作者会做的事。但我认为在这个案例中，很明显它并没有发生。再说一次，这并没有否定耶稣的存在——尽管人们围绕他的出生讲述了许多神迹故事。因为在苏埃托尼乌斯为奥古斯都写的传记中，你也会看到几乎完全相同的描述。
but it's also part of the broader flux that you get across the Roman world and which is exemplified by the figure of Augustus. Yeah. And also, of course, Tom, I mean, we were talking in the previous podcast about an enormous ancient world figure, Alexander the Great, merely because there are elements of his story that we now think are very spurious. it doesn't mean that the whole story is invented that must be true jesus as well otherwise men that's obviously i would assume a formula as well yeah i think so tom before we leave the nativity just one uh more quick question about jesus's birth um well a couple of quick questions. Any idea of a year, roughly?
苏埃托尼乌斯描述说，这是一个名叫尤利乌斯·马拉图斯（Julius Marathas）的奥古斯都解放奴隶（释奴）所叙述的——有些人认为他可能来自巴勒斯坦或叙利亚地区——一个神迹向罗马的所有人发出警示，大自然正在孕育一个将作为国王统治罗马人民的孩子。元老院陷入恐慌，随即投票决定不准当年出生的任何人活下来。所以，你知道，这非常像希律王的故事。所以这里面肯定有一种程式化的成分，对吧？是的，我认为（再次强调），这正是有趣的地方所在，整个圣诞传统、整个故事，它绝对来自于犹太经文的传承，
Kind of maybe, well, no. I mean, sometime between 4 BC and 88. Okay. And Joseph and Mary, any reason to doubt that they're the names of Jesus' parents? Don't think so. So don't think so, as in we may as well just take them on trust. Yeah. Okay. So once Luke, so go back to Luke's gospel.
但它也是罗马世界普遍存在的时代潮流的一部分，而奥古斯都的人物形象就是这种潮流的典范。是的。当然，汤姆，我的意思是，我们在上一期播客中谈到过一位巨大的古代世界人物——亚历山大大帝，仅仅因为他的故事中有些元素现在看来非常虚假，并不意味着整个故事都是虚构的。耶稣身上肯定也是如此，否则……当然，我也会假设这其中有某种程式化。是的，我想是的。汤姆，在我们离开耶稣降生的话题之前，关于耶稣的出生，还有一个简单的小问题——呃，好吧，几个简单的小问题。大约是在哪一年，有个大致概念吗？
Once he's done the nativity, the next chapter, so chapter three, he gets back into a little bit of history, which I like. The 15th year of the reign of Tiberius Caesar, Pontius Pilate being governor of Judea and Herod being tetrarch of Galilee, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Annas and Caiaphas being the high priests. The word of god came unto john the son of zacharias in the wilderness this is john the baptist and he came into all the country about the river jordan preaching the baptism of repentance for the remission of sins so now we've moved on in the story to a different character which is john the baptist who is do you know what i've actually i'm actually quite hazy about john the baptist he
可能是……好吧，没有。我的意思是，在公元前4年到公元6年或7年之间的某个时候。好吧。那么约瑟夫和玛利亚，有什么理由怀疑他们不是耶稣父母的名字吗？不觉得。所以“不觉得”的意思是，我们大可以顺理成章地接受它们。好的。那么一旦路加——让我们回到路加福音。
is the foreigner of jesus who's going around saying you know he's a sort of eschatological apocalyptic prophet is he is that what he's about yes which we should probably explain yeah it's a lot of syllables that so basically he is um he's preaching repentance he's saying that the day of judgment is coming. He compares the coming day of judgment to the cutting down of a fruitless tree. And this is an image that Jesus himself will then repeat. It's a very unusual image. It's not something that you get elsewhere in scripture. So that does suggest that it's John's and then Jesus picks it up. And this is why most scholars, I mean, even the most skeptical would accept that
一旦他讲完了耶稣降生，下一章（也就是第三章），他又回到了我喜欢的一点历史叙事中。提比略·凯撒在位第十五年，本丢·彼拉多作犹太总督，希律作加利利分封王，巴拉巴拉巴拉。亚那和该亚法作大祭司。神的这话临到在旷野的撒迦利亚的儿子约翰——这就是施洗约翰。他就来到约旦河一带地方，宣讲悔改的洗礼，使罪得赦。所以现在我们在故事中转移到了一个不同的角色，那就是施洗约翰。你知不知道，其实我对施洗约翰相当模糊，他
Jesus was crucified and they would accept that Jesus was baptized by John because it's a source of some embarrassment. Because it implies if John is washing people clean so that they're ready for the day of judgment, then it implies that Jesus needs to be washed clean. And there's a bit of kind of, you know, there's a bit of skirting around that issue in the Gospels or kind of reframing of it. So John is a kind of holy man, kind of wandering the wilderness. Yeah, yeah. Preaching to people and washing them. And I would guess, I mean, I'm not an expert on the first century AD or the first century BC by any means, but I'm guessing there are lots of people like John in this world.
是耶稣的先驱，到处对人说（你知道的），他是一个某种末世论的、末日 apocalyptic 的先知吗？他是这样的人吗？是的，我们大概应该解释一下。那个词有很多音节，所以基本上他是在宣讲悔改，他说审判日即将来临。他把即将到来的审判日比作砍伐一棵不结果子的树。这是一个耶稣本人后来会重复的非常不寻常的意象。在经文的其他地方你找不到这样的意象。这确实表明它是约翰的原创，然后耶稣把它捡了起来。这就是为什么大多数学者——我的意思是，即使是最持怀疑态度的学者——也会接受
There are quite a lot, but he is remembered as a significant figure. So he's mentioned by Josephus, talked about that in the last episode, and he comes to a kind of grisly end. He gets put to death by Herod Antipas as a troublemaker. And the story that gets told about him is that, you know, John the Baptist's head gets chopped up because Salome, Herod's daughter, does this erotic dance and all that kind of stuff. I mean, that is, I think, perhaps a slight novelization of what happened. But I think there's no doubt, because both Josephus says it, and it seems to be taken for granted in the Gospels, that John the Baptist is put to death by Herod antipas and that this upsets jesus that jesus is either a follower or in the gospels he's his cousin that um so far as we can tell from the gospels jesus seems to
耶稣曾被钉死在十字架上，并且他们也会接受耶稣曾受约翰施洗，因为这是一件多少有些令人尴尬的事。因为这暗示了如果约翰是在洗净人们，好让他们为审判日做好准备，这就暗示了耶稣也需要被洗净。所以在《福音书》中，对这个问题的处理有些绕弯子，或者说有一种重新构建的意味。所以约翰是个圣人般的角色，在旷野中游荡。是的，是的。向人们讲道并为他们施洗。我猜（我的意思是，我对公元1世纪或公元前1世纪绝对不是什么专家），我猜这个世界上有很多人就像约翰一样。
have regarded antipas with a peculiar contempt because of this so he's very there's no reason to doubt i guess the carpentry is there that they are from a carpentry family his father's carpenter yeah he's a carpenter yeah so he's a workman of some kind but not the poorest of the poor by any means no but not the richest of the rich either so a skilled artisan skilled artisan background and that he now i'm trying to approach this with as a very much 20th century historian that john the the Baptist is, to use modern terminology, the leader of a kind of cult, a baptism cult, that Jesus is his relative or his follower who has been attracted to this. And then having been received into the cult is then very put out when
有相当多的人，但他作为重要人物被人们铭记了。所以他在约瑟夫斯的著作中被提及了——我们在上一集里谈到过，他迎来了某种残酷的结局。他被希律·安提帕斯当作一个麻烦制造者处死了。关于他的流传故事是（你知道的），施洗约翰的头被砍下来，因为希律的女儿莎乐美跳了一段色情的舞蹈，诸如此类。我的意思是，我认为这或许是对发生的事情进行了一点小说化加工。但毫无疑问——因为约瑟夫斯这么说了，而且《福音书》中似乎也把这当作理所当然的事——施洗约翰是被希律·安提帕斯处死的，并且这让耶稣感到难过。耶稣要么是他的追随者，要么在《福音书》里是他的表亲，所以据我们从《福音书》中能够了解到的，耶稣似乎
the leader is executed as a troublemaker. No, I think Jesus is much more independent than that. I think that he gets inspiration perhaps from John. I mean, he comes to John, he learns from John. But the thing that is manifest in the Gospels, and as far as we can tell, is something that is taken for granted by everybody who becomes a Christian, as early as back as we can trace the evidence, is that Jesus has, to put it mildly, a very elevated sense of his role. So he is making incredible claims about himself. But he's not claiming, am I right in thinking, Tom, that he is not explicitly claiming to be the son of God? That's not something he goes around saying.
因为这件事而对安提帕斯怀有一种奇特的蔑视。所以他非常……我猜没有理由怀疑木匠的身份吧？他们来自一个木匠家庭，他的父亲是个木匠。是的，他是个木匠。所以他某种程度上是个工匠，但绝不是最穷的穷人。绝不是，但也不是最富有的富人。所以他有着熟练工匠的背景。现在我正试图从一个20世纪历史学家的角度来探讨：施洗约翰，用现代术语来说，是一个某种教派、洗礼教派的领袖；耶稣是他的亲戚或追随者，被这个教派所吸引。然后，在被这个教派接纳之后，当
I think it's not clear. One of the telling things in the gospels, I think, is that Jesus in his parables and so on, when he portrays kings, seem to be allying the role of the king with himself rather than with God the Father, if you want to put it like that. And he's preaching the coming of the kingdom of God, and we'll perhaps come on to what he means by the kingdom of God. But he is, I mean, I think that he is claiming quite high things for himself because I think otherwise it's impossible to explain why his followers come to assume these things about him. So I guess two really salient pieces of evidence for that would be that he summons, according to the Gospels, 12 followers, 12 disciples, and these approximate to the 12 tribes of Israel, and that the 12 tribes of Israel will be gathered at the end of days by God.
领袖作为麻烦制造者被处决时，耶稣感到非常生气。不，我认为耶稣要独立得多。我认为他或许从约翰那里得到了灵感。我的意思是，他来到约翰那里，向约翰学习。但《福音书》中明显表现出来的一点，而且据我们所能了解的，是每一个成为基督徒的人都视之为理所当然的事情——早在我们能追踪到证据的最早时期——那就是耶稣对自己的角色有着（委婉地说）非常崇高的自我认知。所以他对自我做出了难以置信的宣称。但我没理解错吧，汤姆？他并没有明确宣称自己是神的儿子，对吧？这不是他到处宣扬的东西。
So this seems to be what Jesus is doing. And the other thing is that Jesus is executed for claiming to be king of the Judeans. He is claiming a kingly role. Now, whether that is as God's deputy, whether in some way it's determinist with God's rule, impossible to say. But the seeds of what will become the Christian understanding of Jesus's role, I think, from the evidence of the Gospels and from the evidence of Paul's letters and the trace elements of pre-Pauline teachings within Paul's letters seem to derive from Jesus himself. And I think that this was very much not the consensus, say, in the 70s. And I think now it is much more the consensus. Okay.
我觉得这一点并不明确。我认为《福音书》中说明问题的一点是，耶稣在他的比喻等讲述中，当他描绘国王时，似乎是将国王的角色与他自己联系在一起，而不是与父神联系在一起（如果你想这么说的话）。他在宣讲神国的降临，我们或许会接着谈到他所说的“神国的含义”。但我认为——我的意思是，他在为自己宣称相当高的地位，因为我觉得除此之外，无法解释为什么他的追随者会开始对他产生这些看法。所以我想，其中两个真正突出的证据会是：根据《福音书》，他召集了12个追随者，也就是12个门徒，这近似于以色列的12个支派，而以色列的12个支派将在末日由神聚集。
So it's something probably that Bart Ehrman, who is veryical in general about what we can learn from the Gospels, I mean, he basically accepts that this very, very early understanding of Jesus's elevated role is there pretty much from the beginning. But to go back to Jesus the man, I mean, he lives for, till his early, till 30, early 30s, mid 30s, I'm guessing, or late 20s, maybe. He, for most of that time, he's not doing anything. Am I right? He's presumably just doing carpentry. Well, that's what the gospels imply. And that passage from Luke that you read, you know,
所以这似乎就是耶稣在做的事情。另一件事是，耶稣因为自称是犹太人之王而被处决。他宣称自己具有君王的身份。现在，这究竟是作为神的副手，还是在某种程度上与神的统治具有决定论的联系，这就无法得知了。但未来成为基督教对耶稣角色理解的种子，我认为，从《福音书》的证据、保罗书信的证据，以及保罗书信中前保罗时期教导的残存痕迹来看，似乎都源自耶稣本人。我认为这在70年代绝对不是共识，而我认为现在这已经成为了更多的共识。好吧。
you have the kind of the more mythical elements and then suddenly it's being named, it's specific year, Tiberius, governors, all this, you know, prefects, all this kind you know, prefects, all this kind of thing being absolutely nailed down. And suddenly we're into a record that doesn't really seem to be very long, maybe a year, maybe in John's gospel, three years. And what is Jesus doing in this period? Well, he seems to be claiming the role of a prophet, you know, so that's the John the Baptist role. He's preaching the fact that the day of judgment is coming and that the fruitless tree will be cut down, all that kind of stuff.
所以这可能类似于巴特·埃尔曼（Bart Ehrman）的观点。他对我们能从《福音书》中了解到的内容总体上持非常严苛的态度，我的意思是，他基本上接受了这种关于耶稣崇高地位的非常非常早期的理解，几乎从一开始就存在了。但回到耶稣这个人本身，我的意思是，他一直活到30岁出头、30岁左右、30岁中期，我猜，或者20岁晚期也许吧。在绝大多数时间里，他什么都没做。我没说错吧？他大概只是在做木匠。嗯，这就是《福音书》所暗示的。而你刚才读的那段路加福音的文字，你知道的，
He's a healer. So that's a very important aspect of the stories. And that must be a very, again, just thinking about the stuff that I did when I was at university about holy men in late antiquity. people going around claiming to have powers of various kinds to be healers to cast out demons to exorcise spirits all these kinds of things yeah they're kind of ten a penny aren't they in the levant um in the ancient world in the in the late antique world not ten penny but certainly uh i mean it's not absolutely unheard of. There are a lot of people who are doing this. Yeah. So Jesus is, he's healing people. He's exercising people.
你先是看到了那些偏向神话的元素，然后突然间，它被具体化了，精确到了年份、提比略皇帝、总督们，所有这些（你知道的）总督们，所有这些绝对被钉死在历史实锤上的细节。然后突然之间，我们进入了一段看起来并不算很长的记载，可能是一年，也可能在约翰福音里是三年。那么耶稣在这段时间里在做什么呢？嗯，他似乎在宣称先知的角色（你知道的），所以那是施洗约翰的角色。他宣讲审判日即将来临、不结果子的树将被砍倒等诸如此类的事情。
He's casting out demons. And this is all clearly part of his charismatic appeal. What we as skeptical people in the 21st century are to make of it, I think it's the wrong question. I mean, he's in a world where people accept that these things happen. And whatever it is that he's doing or that people are imagining about him, his charisma is such that clearly people think that he has these powers.
他是个治病的人。所以这是故事中一个非常重要的方面。这一定也是（再次想想我上大学时研究晚期古代圣人时的东西）到处宣称拥有各种力量、能治病、能驱魔、能驱逐邪灵的那些人……所有这些，是的，他们在黎凡特、在古代世界、在晚期古代世界简直就像大白菜一样随处可见，不是大白菜，但绝对……我的意思是，这并非完全闻所未闻。有很多人在这样做。是的。所以耶稣在治愈人们。他在驱魔。
But Tom, what surely is legitimate to say from the perspective of the 21st century is he's not alone in that. That there must have been people over the next hill or three villages away who are doing the same. Absolutely. And not just in Palestine. I mean, this is stuff that's going on across the Roman world. I mean, it wouldn't surprise me if the, you know, the Gaul that we mentioned in the beginning of the first episode
他在赶鬼。这显然都是他具有领袖个人魅力（charisma）的吸引力的一部分。至于我们这些21世纪持怀疑态度的人该如何看待这一切，我认为这是个错误的问题。我的意思是，他身处一个人们接受这些事情会发生的时代。无论他到底在做什么，或者人们对他的想象是什么，他的个人魅力如此之强，以至于人们显然认为他拥有这些力量。
was similarly kind of performing prodigies of healing or whatever. This is something that is happening. The idea that charismatic figures are touched by the supernatural and have power is current. Now, the question is, of course, for Jesus's contemporaries in Galilee and Judea is, is this a malevolent power? Is this a power that is demonic, which is what the rabbis over the course of late antiquity will teach, that Jesus was a disciple of demons. Or is it expressive of what Jesus claims, which is the imminence of the kingdom of God and eschatological, i.e. the idea that the end times are coming. And that's what Albert Schweitzer argued at the beginning of the 20th century. And I think he seems to me clearly right. So eschatology, this is the idea that the world is going to end, that there'll be some sort of apocalypse, that there'll be some kind of- The judgment is coming.
但是汤姆，从21世纪的角度来看，合理的说法难道不是他在其中并不孤单吗？在翻过下一座山或者三个村庄远的地方，肯定也有人在做同样的事。绝对是的。而且不仅在巴勒斯坦。我的意思是，这是整个罗马世界都在发生的事情。如果（你知道的）我们在第一集开头提到的那个高卢人……
Rebirth or whatever. And why is this so common in this period? So the age of the reign of Augustus? Or is it- I don't think it is particularly. Is this absolutely just standard? No, I don't think it is. And I think that that's what makes John the Baptist distinctive. That's what he's preaching. And I think that's what makes Jesus distinctive. And what makes Jesus even more distinctive is that he is laying claim to the role of the judge in this day of judgment. As far as we can tell.
也同样在表演诸如治愈之类的神迹，我一点也不会感到惊奇。这是一直在发生的事情。具有个人魅力的领袖受到超自然力量触碰并拥有权柄的观念，当时是很流行的。现在，问题当然是，对于耶稣在加利利和犹太地的同时代人来说，这是一种恶意的力量吗？这是一种恶魔的力量吗——这正是晚期古代的拉比们日后所教导的，即耶稣是恶魔的门徒？或者，这表达了耶稣所宣称的东西，即神国的迫近和末世论（也就是末日即将来临的观念）？这正是阿尔贝·施韦泽（Albert Schweitzer）在20世纪初所论证的。而且在我看来，他显然是对的。所以末世论，这就是世界将会终结、将会发生某种大灾变、将会出现某种——审判即将来临的观念。
I mean, that is the implication of the parables. So normally when people tell you the end of the world is nigh, they don't then say, and I will be the person who, you know, divides people into sheep and goats. No. They give that role to somebody more potent than themselves. But are you saying Jesus is explicitly saying, and I'm going to be the one who chooses heaven and hell or whatever?
重生或诸如此类。为什么这一时期这种观念如此普遍？所以是在奥古斯都统治的时代？还是说它——我不认为它特别……这难道完全只是常态吗？不，我不认为它是。我认为这正是使施洗约翰与众不同的地方。那是他在宣讲的内容。我认为这也是使耶稣与众不同的地方。而使耶稣更加与众不同的是，他在审判日中自居为审判者的角色。据我们所能了解的。
Well, on the evidence of the gospels, and of course, you know, they're not gospel. But on the evidence of the gospels, and of course, they're not gospel. But on the evidence of the gospels, Jesus is constantly provoking confusion. He's provoking confusion among his critics because he's laying claim to all kinds of things and he's doing all kinds of things that Judeans shouldn't do. He's hanging out with tax collectors.
我的意思是，这就是那些比喻的含义。通常情况下，当人们告诉你世界末日近了时，他们不会接着说：“我将是那个（你知道的）把人和山羊分开的人。”不。他们会把这个角色赋予一个比他们自己更有力量的人。但你是说耶稣明确地在说：“我将是那个选择天堂与地狱或诸如此类的人”吗？
He's hanging out with prostitutes, all this kind of stuff. He's hanging out with the lowest of the low. But his disciples are also confused. And this is arising from the fact that he is claiming an absolutely unheard of authority. But the further strangeness is that this authority, so there is this long tradition going back to the Enlightenment that Jesus was actually a freedom fighter that he was a rebel and in fact it goes back even beyond the enlightenment it goes back so in the time of of diocletian just before um constantine there are skeptical pagan philosophers who are saying that jesus was a rebel that he took to the hills that he was a kind of bandit
嗯，根据《福音书》的证据——当然，（你知道的）它们并不是绝对的真理。但根据《福音书》的证据，耶稣不断地引发混乱。他在他的批评者中引发混乱，因为他自称拥有各种各样的权力，并且他在做各种犹太人不应该做的事情。他跟税吏鬼混。
at the head of rebels yeah so that is a tradition But based on the evidence of the gospels, this is not the case at all. And had Jesus been a rebel, again, it's hard to see why he would have been enshrined as Christian tradition enshrines him, the gospel writers, Paul, the people who exist before Paul. Because the one thing that you get again and again and again throughout the Gospels is that Jesus is proclaiming what he calls the kingdom of God. And this kingdom is not one that is founded in military exploits. It's not one that is founded in the kind of the appurtenances of power. So what Jesus is doing is he's announcing the presence, the imminence, the near arrival of a kingdom that has no political substance whatsoever. And its authority is something that can be felt in the heart. It can't be experienced
他跟妓女鬼混，诸如此类。他跟最底层的人混在一起。但他的门徒也感到困惑。这源于这样一个事实：他宣称拥有史无前例的权威。但更诡异的是这种权威——因此，自启蒙运动以来有一个漫长的传统，即认为耶稣实际上是一个自由斗士，他是一个叛军。事实上，这甚至超越了启蒙运动，一直追溯到戴克里先时期——就在君士坦丁之前，当时有一些持怀疑态度的异教哲学家说耶稣是一个叛军，他逃入山中，他是叛军头目中的某种强盗。
as something that is upheld by soldiers or courts or laws or judges or anything like that. So basically what he's doing, he is preaching the idea of a kingdom of virtue. And this is such a momentous idea. We live with the effects of that in 2022. This idea that there is a kingdom of virtue that transcends the churn of politics, it's such a potent idea. And if it doesn't come from Jesus, then where does it come from? Are the gospel writers just making it up? I mean, it seems improbable. And so the likeliest explanation as far as I'm concerned is that it does derive from Jesus, then where does it come from? Are the gospel writers just making it up? I mean, it seems improbable. And so the likeliest explanation, as far as I'm concerned, is that it does derive from Jesus, you know, on the principle of Occam's razor. He isn't drawing on something, I don't know, all kinds of strands and traditions that are around in the first century AD. He is.
是的，所以这是一个传统。但根据《福音书》的证据，情况根本不是这样。如果耶稣是个叛军，同样很难看出他为什么会被基督教传统、福音书作者、保罗以及保罗之前存在的人们所尊崇。因为你在《福音书》中一次又一次、一遍又一遍看到的最重要的一点是，耶稣在宣告他所说的“神国”。而这个国度并不是建立在军事功勋之上的。它不是建立在权力的外表之上的。所以耶稣所做的是，他宣告了一个毫无政治实质的国度的存在、迫近、即将来临。它的权威是一种可以在心中感受到的东西。它无法作为一种由士兵、法庭、法律、法官或诸如此类的事物所维系的东西来体验。所以基本上他在做的事情，他是在宣讲美德之国的观念。这是一个如此重大的观念。我们在2022年仍然生活在它的影响之下。这种认为存在一个超越政治更迭的美德之国的观念，是一个如此强有力的观念。如果它不是来自耶稣，那它又是从哪里来的？难道福音书作者只是在凭空捏造吗？我的意思是，这看起来不太可能。所以在我看来，最可能的解释是它确实源自耶稣。如果它不是来自耶稣，那它从何而来？难道福音书作者是在捏造吗？这很不合情理。所以在我看来，最合理的解释是它确实源自耶稣，你知道的，本着奥卡姆剃刀原理。他并不是在借鉴什么——我不知道，公元1世纪周遭的各种思潮和传统。他确实是在借鉴。
Absolutely. I mean, he's deeply steeped in scripture. Of course he is, but he is, I don't know, he's, he's laying claim to a rock that he's going to sit in judgment, that he, he is going to preside over the kingdom of God. And again, I think it goes back to this idea that we talked, I talked about at the very end of the previous episode, this idea that he is situated between the dimension of the temple and the temple authorities and all that kind of stuff and the kind of the Roman world of supernatural power. And he is saying that he is emancipating himself and those who follow him from those dimensions because I think he sees the supernatural dimension of the temple, let alone the supernatural dimension of Roman power,
绝对的。我的意思是，他深深浸润在经文中。他当然是的，但他是——我不知道，他在——他宣称有一块磐石，他将坐在上面进行审判，他将主宰神国。再说一次，我认为这可以追溯到我们讨论过的话题——我在上一集的最后谈到过的那个观念：他处于圣殿与圣殿当局等诸如此类的事物之间的维度，以及罗马超自然权力世界之间。而他宣称自己正在将自己和追随者从这些维度中解放出来，因为我认为他看到圣殿的超自然维度（更不用说罗马权力的超自然维度了），
as being too much a part of the world. And the kingdom of God is not, in that sense, when he comes before Pilate and he says, my kingdom is not of this world, that's what he's meaning. But it's something that in the context of the world that he is in, is experienced as something strange and kind of unfathomable, and yet also incredibly powerful. And that, I think, is the key of why he gets the followers that he does and why he's commemorated in the way that he is. So there are two elements I want to ask about, Tom, before we go to a break. Number one follows on from what you've been saying. So in the first podcast, you were talking about the context of Galilee in the first century AD and about what I rather tritely called a kind of emerging culture war between people who liked Roman pots and metropolitan things like you
已经过多地成为了这个世界的一部分。而神国并非如此——在这个意义上，当他来到彼拉多面前说“我的国不属这个世界”时，他指的就是这个。但在他身处的那个世界的背景下，这被体验为一种奇异的、不可捉摸的、却又无比强大的东西。而我认为，这就是他为什么能拥有那些追随者、为什么他会以那种方式被纪念的关键所在。所以在我们进入中场休息之前，我想问汤姆两个元素。第一点延续了你刚才一直在说的话。所以在第一播客中，你在谈到公元1世纪加利利的背景时，谈到了我颇有些老套地称之为“喜欢罗马陶罐和诸如你这样大都市事物的人”与“像我这样质朴、地道、脚踏实地的民众”之间正在显现的文化战争。而你刚才描述耶稣的方式，他在吸引社会底层的人。他说会有一个不属于权力和财富之类事物的国度。最后的将要成为最先的，最先的将要成为最后的。
and people like me who were earthy, authentic, salt of the earth kind of people. And the way you're describing Jesus there, he's appealing to people at the bottom. He's saying there'll be a kingdom that is not one of power and wealth and all that sort of stuff. The last shall be first and the first shall be last. Precisely. So there are people who've written about him, kind of biographers and people exploring the historical Jesus, who've seen him as a kind of, dare I say, a kind of proto-socialist, a kind of social radical, a prophet of social change. Is that at all reasonable? The kingdom of God is not of this earth.
恰恰如此。所以有些人写过关于他的文章，比如传记作家和探索历史中耶稣的人，他们把他看作某种——我敢说——某种准社会主义者、某种社会激进分子、社会变革的先知。这有任何合理性吗？神国不属于这个世界。
So he's not a socialist in that sense. He's preaching something stranger. He's preaching the idea that in some way, the just will be rewarded, the hungry will be fed, the thirsty will get water, and the last last will be first and the first will be last tom you'd be a great vicar you're such a loss to the vicaring profession and the strangeness of it i think is what leads him to be put to death because he is seen as a menacing figure by both the judean temple authorities and in the due course by the Romans, because he's attacking the claims to divine authority of both the temple priesthood and of Pilate as Caesar's representative. Yeah.
所以他在那个意义上不是社会主义者。他在宣讲一种更奇异的东西。他在宣讲这样一种观念：在某种程度上，正直的人将得到回报，饥饿的人将得到饱足，口渴的人将得到水，最后的人将成为最先的，最先的人将成为最后的。汤姆，你会是一个很棒的牧师，牧师这个行业失去你可真是个损失。而且我认为，这种奇异性导致他被处死，因为他和犹太圣殿当局以及后来的罗马人都将其视为一个具有威胁的人物，因为他在攻击圣殿祭司阶层和彼拉多作为凯撒代表的神圣权威的主张。是的。
But he is still appealing to people who are not normally appealed to, isn't he? He is. You know, prostitutes, tax collectors, whatever. He is. I mean, so the kingdom of heaven manifests itself in all kinds of subversions. Right. Okay. So he's a subversive. He all kinds of subversions. Right. Okay.
但他仍然在吸引那些通常不会被吸引的人，不是吗？是的。你知道的，妓女、税吏，诸如此类。他是的。我的意思是，所以天国在各种颠覆中彰显了它自己。对吧？所以他是一个颠覆者。他……各种颠覆。对吧？
So he's a subversive. He's a very subversive. He's a very subversive figure. Yeah. He's an incredibly subversive figure. Now, my second question slightly cuts against that. Is he the Jewish Messiah? or maybe you would say Judean, prophetic tradition that a king, a descendant of David, will arise and lead the children of Israel to who knows what, some new golden age.
所以他是一个颠覆者。他是一个非常颠覆性的……他是一个非常颠覆性的人物。是的。他是一个极其颠覆性的人物。现在，我的第二个问题略微与此相左。他是犹太人的弥赛亚吗？或者你可能会说是犹太（Judean）的先知传统，即一个国王、一个大卫的后代将会兴起，并带领以色列的子民走向谁知道什么样的新黄金时代。
Is he consciously laying claim to that? I think he is, because I think that it's very difficult to understand otherwise why the Romans would have crucified him. And it's also very difficult to understand why after his death his followers would have enshrined him as the messiah would have thought of him as the messiah because you know i mean okay so they think he's risen from the dead that in itself would not be sufficient to make it obvious that he's the messiah so i think that that all the evidence suggests that jesus must have laid claim to that and the whole thing about him entering jerusalem say on the on the donkey all that evidence suggests that Jesus must have laid claim to that. And the whole thing about him entering Jerusalem, say, on the donkey, all that kind of stuff suggests that this is, I think, part of what he's teaching.
他是在有意识地宣称这一点吗？我认为他是的，因为我觉得很难用其他方式来解释为什么罗马人会把他钉死在十字架上。同样也很难解释为什么在他死后，他的追随者会把他奉为弥赛亚，会认为他是弥赛亚——因为（你知道的，好吧，即使他们认为他从死里复活了，这本身也不足以让人显而易见地认为他就是弥赛亚）。所以我觉得所有的证据都表明，耶稣必定宣称过这一点。关于他骑着驴进入耶路撒冷的所有证据，都表明了这一点。所以所有这些证据都表明，耶稣必定宣称过这一点。关于他骑着驴进入耶路撒冷的所有证据，诸如此类的事情都表明，我认为这是他教导的一部分。
So we are going to come to a break in a second. But just before, you were talking a little bit earlier about this thing about whether or not he's a freedom fighter, bandit who takes the hills or whatever. But if he is proclaiming himself the Jewish Messiah, that is an explicitly political claim, isn't it? It's not just a kind of theological supernatural claim. We go back to the strangeness of this idea of the kingdom of God, that he is situating the kingdom of God beyond the dimensions of, as he sees it earthly kingdom so you know he goes to the temple and in
所以我们马上要进入中场休息。但在那之前，你刚才稍微谈到了关于他是否是一个逃入山中的自由斗士、强盗之类的说法。但如果他宣告自己是犹太人的弥赛亚，那是一个明确的政治主张，对吧？它不仅仅是一个神学的、超自然的主张。让我们回到神国这个观念的奇异性上来——他把神国定位在（正如他所看到的）世俗国度的维度之外。所以（你知道的）他去了圣殿，在
the synoptic accounts it's after that that he's brought this question by the pharisees who are trying to trip him up should we pay taxes to caesar yeah and he asks for a coin and he can do this because in galilee there are no roman coins but in judea there are and he's shown that the coin and he says whose head is that and the pharisee replies caesar and so he famously replies render unto caesar what is caesar's and render unto god what is god and this is it's a brilliant riposte but it's also an acorn from which a mighty oak will grow it's it and that oak is you know it's the secular tradition that we inhabit so that oak is your book dominion tom pretty much pretty much and and this is a kind of you know this is an
对观福音的记载中，正是在那之后，法利赛人拿这个问题来难为他，试图绊倒他：“我们纳税给凯撒可以吗？”是的。他要了一个硬币——他能这样做是因为在加利利没有罗马硬币，但在犹太地有——他展示了那硬币并问：“这是谁的头像？”法利赛人回答：“凯撒。”于是他给出了著名的回答：“凯撒的物当归给凯撒，神的物当归给神。”这是一个绝妙的反击，但它也是一粒将长成参天大树的橡果。这棵大树就是（你知道的）我们所栖息的世俗传统。所以那棵大树就是你的书《统治》（Dominion），汤姆。差不多，差不多。而这是一种（你知道的）——
incredibly radical subversive and yet poetic teaching it's not the teaching of of a revolutionary it's not the teacher of someone who is raising the sword against the romans or anything like that but it is the teaching of someone whose concept of a kingdom that transcends earthly power will have this stupefying, I mean, kind of an impact so profound that it's almost impossible to measure. Its impact has been so overwhelming that we don't even recognize it for what it is. And this is where it begins. To play the skeptic again though, Tom, is it not possible that that is a detail inserted later on precisely because the early Christians want this creed to thrive in the Roman world? So they put in this detail, which is unthreatening,
难以置信地激进、颠覆而又充满诗意的教导，这不是一个革命者的教导，这不是一个对罗马人或类似的人挥舞刀剑的人的老师，但这是一个人的教导，他的王国概念超越了世俗权力，会产生这种麻木的，我的意思是，这种深远的影响几乎无法衡量。它的影响如此压倒性，以至于我们甚至没有认清它的本来面目。这就是一切的开始。不过，汤姆，再次扮演怀疑论者，难道那种细节不是后来才插入的，恰恰是因为早期基督徒希望这种信条在罗马世界蓬勃发展吗？所以他们加入了这个细节，这是没有威胁的，
ostentatiously unthreatening to Roman political order. I mean, that is one perspective that you could bring, but I think that that is reflective of someone who's been steeped in the study of 20th century political propaganda, or the way that things are marketed. Because why would Christians be risking their lives to preach something that they were simultaneously faking. And the other thing is that that formulation, render unto Caesar, I mean, it's brilliant and it's subversive. Yeah. Who would make it up? I mean, who would come up with that if not someone who was a brilliant preacher and had a very, very weird understanding in the context of the age
对罗马的政治秩序没有显露威胁。我的意思是，这是一种你可以持有的观点，但我认为这反映了一个沉浸在20th世纪政治宣传研究中或营销方式中的人。因为为什么基督徒要冒着生命危险去宣扬他们同时也在伪造的东西呢？另一件事是，那个公式，凯撒的归凯撒，我的意思是，它太 brillante（精彩）了，而且是颠覆性的。是的。谁会编造它呢？我的意思是，如果不是一个出色的传教士，并且在那个时代的背景下对什么是权力有着非常非常奇怪的理解，谁会想出这个呢？
of what power was and it seems likely to me that that person was jesus because that's what the gospels are claiming and that's what the evidence of of how he comes to be reverenced by his followers after his death is pointing to rather than that it's some you know slimy uh pr guy trying to trying to market his new you know this new cult to gullible Romans. The Peter Mandelson of the... Yeah, I mean, that seems a very, very 21st century perspective that does not, I think, correspond to the evidence.
在我看来，那个人很可能就是耶稣，因为福音书就是这么声称的，这也是在他死后他的追随者如何崇拜他的证据所指的方向，而不是说他是个什么（你知道的）油腔滑调的公关人员，试图向易受骗的罗马人推销他的新（你知道的）这个新邪教。皮特·曼德尔森……是的，我的意思是，这看起来是一个非常非常21st世纪的视角，我认为这与证据不符。
Oh, shame. I've let myself down. I've let you down. I've let the Bobcats down. You've let God down. I have done. Right. And on that note, I think we should take a break while I try to recover my composure
哦，真遗憾。我让自己失望了。我让你失望了。我让山猫队失望了。你让上帝失望了。我确实做到了。好吧。顺便说一句，我想我们应该休息一下，同时我试着恢复我的镇静
and some degree of self-respect. And we will return with the rest of the life of Jesus and the death and the resurrections. What on earth is going on there? Tom is going to solve the mystery, which is so exciting. So we'll be back after the break. And I'm Richard Osman, and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com Welcome back to The Rest Is History. So there's been some strange goings on in this podcast, Tom. You pouring cold water on the nativity, a very dark moment in the history of The Rest Is History.
和某种程度的自尊。我们将带着耶稣生命的剩余部分以及死亡和复活归来。这到底是怎么回事？汤姆将解开这个谜团，真是太令人兴奋了。所以我们休息后会回来。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝秀场八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告、独家剧集并提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com 欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》。所以在这个播客中发生了一些奇怪的事情，汤姆。你给圣诞降生泼冷水，《剩下的就是历史》历史上非常黑暗的一个时刻。
But we've got some really strange stuff to come because we've got, of course, Jesus' passion, the crucifixion, the resurrection, and then the growth of his reputation. I was about to say his cult. Well, that's one way of putting it. Yes, the growth of his reputation. The growth of his reputation. Well, he had a tremendous fan club, Tom. Indeed. Okay, so where did we get to?
但接下来我们会有一些非常奇怪的事情，因为我们有，当然，耶稣的受难、钉十字架、复活，然后是他声誉的增长。我差点要说他的崇拜。嗯，这也是一种说法。是的，他声誉的增长。他声誉的增长。嗯，他有一个巨大的粉丝俱乐部，汤姆。确实。好吧，那么我们讲到哪儿了？
So Jesus has been wandering around. He's been healing people or appearing to heal people. He's been appearing to or indeed carrying out miracles. He has been preaching the arrival of the kingdom of heaven. Yeah. And he has gone into Jerusalem. Well, so according to the synoptic gospel, say Mark, Matthew and Luke,
所以耶稣一直在四处游历。他一直在治愈人们，或者表现得像是在治愈人们。他一直在表现得像是在实施，或者确实在实施神迹。他一直在宣扬天国的降临。是的。他已经进入了耶路撒冷。嗯，根据对观福音书，比方说马可、马太和路加，
this is the one time he's been in Galilee and then he says he's going to Jerusalem for the Passover. And there's a sense in which going to Jerusalem, he's putting his head in the noose because he's coming up against both the temple authorities and the Romans. He's not really in favor of either of them. And this is what will culminate in his death.
这是他唯一一次在加利利，然后他说他要去耶路撒冷过逾越节。从某种意义上说，去耶路撒冷就像是将自己的脑袋套进绞索，因为他同时在对抗圣殿当局和罗马人。他实际上并不支持他们中的任何一个。这就是最终导致他死亡的原因。
And again, there's the question of what is he doing? So there are two things that he does that kind of attracts the eye. There's the thing, you know, he rides in on the donkey. And then there's the thing that he overturns the tables of the money changers in the temple. Yeah. And he genuinely, he causes a ruckus. I mean, he seems to kind of, you know, get kind of really annoyed. I mean, the presence of currency in the temple seems to infuriate him,
同样，这里有个问题：他在做什么？所以他做了两件吸引眼球的事情。一件是，你知道的，他骑着驴进城。然后另一件事是，他推翻了圣殿里兑换银币者的桌子。是的。而且他是真心实意的，他引起了一场骚乱。我的意思是，他似乎有点，你知道的，变得真的很生气。我的意思是，圣殿里出现货币似乎激怒了他，
you know, in a way that he's not shown as getting infuriated in any other way. And again, I think it's hard to know otherwise why he would have provoked the fury of the temple authorities unless this was something that actually happened. So again, I'm happy to think that this is something that happened and that it's reflective of everything that he most hates about the temple, the way in which the worship of God, the kingdom of God has been corrupted and polluted by people making money. The riding in on the donkey. So this is either a conscious attempt to- I think it's a conscious attempt. To live up to the prophecies of
你知道的，以一种他在其他任何事情上都没有表现出的愤怒方式。再说一次，我认为很难知道除了这种情况之外，他为什么会激怒圣殿当局，除非这是真实发生的事情。所以再次，我很高兴认为这是真实发生的事情，并且这反映了他对圣殿最痛恨的一切，上帝的崇拜、上帝的王国被那些赚钱的人腐蚀和污染的方式。骑着驴进城。所以这要么是有意识地试图——我认为这是有意识地试图。活出那些关于
i don't know to brand himself as the messiah so it's been prophesied that the messiah will arrive in jerusalem on a donkey why why a donkey well it's you know the prophecy is rejoice greatly o daughter of zion shout aloud o daughter of jerusalem lo your king comes to you triumphant and victorious is he humble and riding on a donkey on a colt the foal of a donkey that's a weird detail isn't it i mean why would it is a a donkey. That's a weird detail, isn't it? I mean, why would someone have to say that? It is a weird detail. And yet I think that the thing that's weird about it is that a king would ride on a donkey. Yeah, exactly.
我不知道，将自己塑造为弥赛亚的预言，所以预言说弥赛亚将骑着驴到达耶路撒冷，为什么是驴，嗯，你知道的，预言是“锡安的民哪，应当大大喜乐；耶路撒冷民哪，应当欢呼。看哪，你的王来到你这里！他是公义的，并且施行拯救，谦谦和和地骑着驴，就是骑着驴的驹子。”这是一个奇怪的细节，不是吗？我的意思是，为什么会有人这么说？这是一个奇怪的细节。然而我认为它奇怪的地方在于，一个国王竟然会骑着驴。是的，没错。
Rather than on a war horse, on Persepolis. I suspect that Jesus has meditated on the implications of this. Because the idea that the kingdom is not of this earth seems to be the bedrock of his take on things. And so you can see why that's a prophecy that perhaps would particularly appeal to him. And the subversive element of it, that a king on a donkey, he must have enjoyed that.
而不是骑着战马，骑着帕尔塞波利斯。我怀疑耶稣曾沉思过这其中的含义。因为国度不属于这个世界的想法似乎是他对事物看法的基石。所以你可以理解为什么那是一个可能特别吸引他的预言。以及其中的颠覆性元素，一个骑着驴的国王，他一定很享受这一点。
Well, it's there. Yes, exactly. Yes. And it's something perhaps that he's picked up on that others haven't. And then the tables of the money changers always amuse me. So anyone who's ever changed money at an airport will have strong views as I do about travel. Yeah, you want to smash them up.
嗯，它就在那里。是的，没错。是的。这也许是他注意到而其他人没有注意到的东西。然后兑换银币者的桌子总是让我觉得好笑。所以任何在机场换过钱的人都会有强烈的看法，就像我对旅行的看法一样。是的，你想砸碎它们。
Yes. Why are people changing money in the temple? What's going on there? What's they changing? They're changing currency? What are they doing? Because if you're making a temple offering, you can't present it with the heads of, say, of Caesar on it or anything that would be offensive to God.
是的。为什么人们要在圣殿里换钱？那里发生了什么？他们在换什么？他们在换货币？他们在做什么？因为如果你要进行圣殿奉献，你不能拿着上面印有，比如说，凯撒头像的东西，或者任何会冒犯上帝的东西来献上。
So they have to be changed. Okay. And so why does he object to this? Because he sees it as the intrusion of everything that is most earthly and corrupting into the place that properly should be holiest. If the kingdom of God is not of this earth, that sense of the tension between the kingdom of God and the earthliness of the way that humans live is most manifest in the temple. Yeah.
所以它们必须被兑换。好的。那么他为什么要反对这一点？因为他认为这是所有最世俗、最具腐蚀性的东西对本该最神圣的地方的侵入。如果上帝的国不属于这个世界，那么上帝的国与人类生活的世俗性之间的这种紧张感在圣殿中最为明显。是的。
I think that that's what's getting his goat. And that, of course, is then what makes him, you he's he's kind of thrown a gauntlet down yeah because i've secretly been doing my own reading on this tom have you believe i read an essay by e.p sanders of duke university and he said that it was this who died a couple of weeks ago very sad right exactly this this sort of alleged misconduct in the temple this ruckus was actually what did for Jesus, because the temple authorities were absolutely aghast and said, he's got to go. Yeah. And I think that the reason they're aghast isn't just that they feel that Jesus is striking
我认为这就是让他抓狂的地方。当然，这也是让他，你知道的，他已经抛出了战书，因为我最近一直在秘密阅读这方面的资料，汤姆。真的吗？我读了一篇杜克大学的E.P.桑德斯写的文章，他说就是这个几周前去世的人，非常悲伤，对，没错，这种所谓的在圣殿中的不当行为，这场骚乱，实际上才是真正害死耶稣的原因，因为圣殿当局感到极其震惊，并说：他必须得走。是的。我认为他们感到震惊的原因不仅是因为他们觉得耶稣在打击
at their authority. I think more importantly, they're anxious about the trigger-happy nature of the Romans, because this is Passover, the city is heaving. The whole basis of priestly power depends on their ability to serve up to the Romans, you know, a stable, riot-free scenario over the Passover. And so Jesus is clearly a threat. And that, I think, is why he gets arrested. And I think that looking at the evidence from Josephus, there's nothing about this narrative that seems particularly implausible. I mean, to repeat, some of the details of the passion narrative, I think are garnished, are probably implausible, but the overall sweep of it does seem to be true. And it revolves around this issue that we still don't really know is,
他们的权威。我认为更重要的是，他们对罗马人容易冲动的性格感到焦虑，因为这是逾越节，城里挤满了人。祭司权力的整个基础取决于他们是否有能力在逾越节期间为罗马人提供一个稳定、免于暴乱的局面。所以耶稣显然是一个威胁。我认为这就是他被捕的原因。而且我认为，看看来自约瑟夫斯的证据，这个叙事的任何部分看起来都没有特别难以置信的。我的意思是，重申一下，受难叙事的一些细节，我认为是经过修饰的，可能是难以置信的，但它的整体宏观走向似乎是真的。它围绕着这样一个问题：我们仍然不太清楚，
does the high priest have the power to put people to death or does he have to get the Romans to do it? And the only way that they can get the Romans to do it is to persuade the Romans that Jesus is actually a rebel. And so that again is kind of the bedrock of the passion narrative, Jesus being handed over to Pilate, who then interrogates him, and Jesus refusing to answer. So I think that, again, I suspect that this is something that is historical, that Jesus accepts his fate, that he willingly accepts his fate. This is something that is emphasized within the Gospels and that he maintains his silence because he's not there to engage in political debate or religious debate with the Romans or with the high priests. Because the thing is, is that it's not as though the priests, by sending Jesus to Pilate, is sending him to a secular authority. He isn't. Pilate is based in Caesarea, which is the city named after the divine Augustus, the deified Augustus. Pilate is the representative, again, of a kind of distinctively supernatural understanding of the world that to Jesus is is profoundly offensive and so that's why i think he's not engaging with it but jesus has already had the last supper at which he has basically
大祭司是否有权处死人，还是必须让罗马人来做这件事？他们唯一能让罗马人这么做的办法，就是说服罗马人耶稣实际上是一个叛军。所以这再次成为受难叙事的基石，耶稣被交给彼拉多，彼拉多随后审讯他，而耶稣拒绝回答。所以我认为，再次地，我怀疑这是一件历史事件，耶稣接受了他的命运，他甘愿接受自己的命运。这是福音书中所强调的事情，他保持沉默，因为他不是去与罗马人或大祭司进行政治辩论或宗教辩论的。因为问题在于，并不是说祭司们把耶稣送到彼拉多那里，就是把他送给了一个世俗权威。他并没有。彼拉多驻扎在凯撒利亚，这是一座以神圣的奥古斯都、被神化的奥古斯都命名的城市。彼拉多同样是那种对世界有着截然不同的超自然理解的代表，对耶稣来说，这种理解是极其令人反感的，所以这就是为什么我认为他没有参与其中，但耶稣已经吃过了最后的晚餐，在晚餐上他基本上
implied that he's going that he's going and there's the stuff with the body and the blood and again the detail that the record of this is incredibly early because it's attested to in paul's letters as something that is already a formula. So presumably this is being repeated maybe, you know, years after, very, very soon after Jesus' death. And do we know, Tom, where this comes from? Where does all this come from? Well, I think it probably comes from memories of Jesus. Now that doesn't mean that it's exact, you know, they're not taking, you know, they're not filming it on iPhones or anything. It's not an exact transcription, but almost everything that Jesus says, and almost everything perhaps more in the way that, say, a journalist today
暗示了他要离开，他要离开了，还有关于身体和血液的事情，同样，关于这方面的记录的细节极其早期，因为保罗的书信中证明了这一点，它已经是一个公式了。所以据此推测，这可能在耶稣死后几年，非常非常快的时间里就被不断重复。汤姆，我们知道这来自哪里吗？这一切都从何而来？嗯，我认为它可能来自于对耶稣的记忆。现在这并不意味着它是准确的，你知道的，他们当时没有用iPhone拍摄或者别的什么。这不是准确的转录，但耶稣所说几乎所有的话，以及也许更多的话，就像今天的一位记者
might or a historian today might. You know, the disciples have been going around with Jesus. He's got his stump speech. He's got these formulations. He's got these kind of memorable phrases. He's got these memorable stories, and they remember them. And they may not be exactly word for word. They may not be verbatim. But I think the likelihood is that they do reflect the authentic speeches of this man because they have a kind of inherent integrity. They have an inherent coherence and they are so striking and they're so memorable that if they didn't come from Jesus, then where did they come from? Who's making them up? So the body and the blood, are they rooted in Jewish thought, Tom? This seems to revolve around the idea that Jesus is the lamb that gets sacrificed at the Passover.
或今天的历史学家可能会做的那样。你知道的，门徒们一直跟着耶稣到处走。他有他的竞选演讲。他有这些公式。他有这些令人难忘的短语。他有这些令人难忘的故事，他们都记住了。它们可能不是逐字逐句的。它们可能不是原话。但我认为很有可能它们确实反映了这个男人的真实讲话，因为它们具有一种内在的完整性。它们具有内在的连贯性，而且它们如此引人注目，如此令人难忘，如果它们不是来自耶稣，那它们又是从哪里来的？是谁编造的呢？所以身体和血液，它们植根于犹太思想吗，汤姆？这似乎围绕着这样一个想法：耶稣是在逾越节被献祭的羔羊。
Right. And again, it's such a kind of odd idea. I mean, it's kind of simultaneously rooted in Judean tradition and yet kind of so offensive to it. But it seems very Jesus-ish. I mean, it's such a word. And again, it's very, very early. So the likelihood is, it seems to me, that it corresponds to something that actually happened and that the lamb goes willingly to its death. And But Celsus says, Jesus on the cross, he ends up kind of complaining against God. And this is very undignified behavior.
对。同样，这是一个非常奇怪的想法。我的意思是，它一方面植根于犹太传统，但另一方面又对它如此具有冒犯性。但它看起来非常像耶稣会做的事。我的意思是，这是一个这样的词。而且，它非常非常早期。所以在我看来，它很可能对应于真实发生的事情，并且羔羊甘愿走向死亡。而且但是刻尔苏斯说，十字架上的耶稣，他最后有点在抱怨上帝。这是一种非常不得体的行为。
This is not the kind of thing. But actually, the thing that's really striking about the parish narratives is that Jesus says almost nothing. It's only at the very end that he has this. Yeah. You know, he cries out in his agony. And he's crucified as a slave. That's standard Roman. He's crucified as a slave. That's standard Roman. He's crucified as a rebel.
这不是那种事情。但事实上，关于受难叙事真正引人注目的是，耶稣几乎什么也没说。直到最后他才有这个。是的。你知道的，他在痛苦中呼喊。他作为奴隶被钉死在十字架上。那是标准的罗马做法。他作为奴隶被钉死在十字架上。那是标准的罗马做法。他作为叛军被钉死在十字架上。
Right. But it's a punishment for slaves, isn't it? For outcasts, for people on the fringe. Yes. It's the most humiliating death that you can devise. And for the King of the Jews to suffer the death of a slave is obviously a way for the Romans to affirm the triumph of the Roman order. And Paul, writing maybe 20 years later, is very specific that Jesus is put to death by the rulers of this age. So again, this is kind of counterpointing the eternity that is the kingdom of heaven against the specific earthly claim to status of Caesar and his servants.
对。但这是对奴隶的惩罚，不是吗？对被抛弃的人，对边缘化的人。是的。这是你能设计出的最具羞辱性的死亡。对于犹太人的王来说，遭受奴隶般的死亡显然是罗马人宣示罗马秩序胜利的一种方式。保罗大约在20年后写作时，非常明确地指出耶稣是被这个时代的统治者处死的。所以这再次将天国的永恒与凯撒及其奴仆特定的世俗地位宣称进行对比。
But then, Tom, the twist that elevates this above all other stories, the resurrection. And this is something, so going back to what I was reading from E.P. Sanders, he says, pretty much what you were saying, if you were going to create a fraud, if you were going to make this up, you would at least make sure that the stories matched and that they weren't full of inconsistencies and they weren't so strange. And E.P. Sanders says, you know, Jesus, it's very clear he's not a ghost, nor is he somebody who has survived crucifixion and is kind of covered in blood. So in the Gospels, the resurrected Jesus is kind of defined almost in terms of what he's not. The sense you get is that they are struggling to explain what it is that they've experienced.
但是，汤姆，将这个故事提升到所有其他故事之上的转折点，复活。这是某件——所以回到我从E.P.桑德斯那里读到的内容，他说，基本上就像你所说的那样，如果你打算制造一个骗局，如果你打算编造这个，你至少会确保这些故事是匹配的，它们不会充满矛盾，也不会那么奇怪。E.P.桑德斯说，你知道的，耶稣，很明显他不是鬼魂，也不是那种在十字架上幸存下来、浑身是血的人。所以在福音书中，复活的耶稣在某种程度上几乎是通过他“不是”什么来定义的。你得到的印象是，他们在极力解释他们所经历的到底是什么。
And again, I have no doubt that they did experience something. Now, what that experience was is a totally different question. That's beyond the remit of a history podcast to discuss. But it does seem to me a basic historical fact that they must have experienced something. Because again, it's why otherwise would they have believed what they believed? And the thing is that the resurrection in itself is not what proves to them that Jesus is the Messiah and in due course, the son of God. That seems to be rooted in what Jesus himself had taught.
再说一次，我毫不怀疑他们的确历了某种经历。至于那究竟是什么经历，则是完全不同的另一个问题。这超出了历史播客的讨论范围。但在我看来，一个基本的历史事实是，他们必定经历过某种事情。因为同样地，否则他们怎么会相信自己所相信的呢？关键在于，复活本身并不是向他们证明耶稣是弥赛亚、并在后来成为上帝之子的证据。这似乎根植于耶稣本人所教导的内容。
But the fact that he rises from the dead seems to them to have suddenly things that Jesus had told them made sense, and it kind of clicks. Now, of course, there are all kinds of other theories as to what might have happened. And one of them is mentioned in the gospels itself. So it's mentioned by Matthew. So he describes how some of the guard went into the city and told the chief priests everything that had happened. So this is the discovery of the guard went into the city and told the chief priests everything that happened. So this is, you know, the discovery of the empty tomb. And after the priests had assembled with the elders, they devised a plan to give a large sum of money to the soldiers, telling them, you must say his disciples came by night and stole him away while we were asleep.
但耶稣从死里复活这一事实，似乎让他们突然觉得耶稣以前对他们说过的话都有了意义，一切都豁然开朗了。当然，关于当时可能发生了什么，还有各种各样的其他理论。其中之一在福音书本身中就提到了。马太福音就提到了这一点。他描述了几个卫兵如何进城，把发生的一切都告诉了祭司长。所以这就是发现空墓的过程。祭司们与长老开会商议后，就想出一个计策，拿许多银钱给兵丁，说：你们要这样说：夜间我们睡觉的时候，他的门徒来把他偷去了。
So the fact that that's in Matthew's gospel implies that that is a theory that is kind of current. So they cut him down before he was dead? Well, that's another theory. That's another theory. But the theory that is mentioned in Matthew's Gospels is that the disciples came and stole the body from the tomb. Right. So in other words, it's a fraud perpetrated by the disciples. But that wouldn't explain the walking around and hobnobbing with people on roads to Emmaus
所以这个内容出现在马太福音中，意味着那是一个正在流传的理论。所以他们在死前就把他放下来了？嗯，那是另一个理论。那是另一个理论。但马太福音中提到的理论是，门徒们来到墓前偷走了尸体。对。换句话说，这是门徒们精心策划的一个骗局。但这无法解释他在路上走来走去，与人交际，比如去以马忤斯的路上
or whatever. Okay. So again, the priests would probably say this is all just made on roads to Emmaus or whatever. Okay. So again, the priest would probably say this is all just made up, that this is a fantasy. Yeah. There is another theory that Jesus was never crucified. So that's the theory that you get in the Gospel of Basilides,
或者诸如此类的事情。好的。所以同样的，祭司们可能会说这全都是在去以马忤斯的路上或诸如此类的地方凭空捏造的。好的。所以再次，祭司可能会说这全都是捏造的，这是一种幻想。还有另一种理论认为耶稣从未被钉死在十字架上。这就是你在巴西利德斯福音书中看到的理论，
where this other guy, Simon of Cyrene, who carries the cross is supposed to have been crucified. It's also the story that you get in the Quran in due course. Right. Celsus, the guy who has his run in with origin so this is in the early third century he says that these are hallucinations that these are a kind of ignorant peasants who you know are prone to mad fantasies put on your 21st century skeptic hat your humanist hat if you like if you will you would say these are
其中另一个背十字架的人，古利奈人西门，被认为是被钉死在十字架上了。这也是你在稍后的《古兰经》中读到的故事。对。刻尔苏斯，那个与俄利根有过节的人，也就是在公元三世纪初，他说这些都是幻觉，这些是一群无知无觉的农民，你知道的，他们容易产生疯狂的幻想。如果你戴上21st世纪的怀疑论者帽子，如果你愿意的话，戴上你的人文主义者帽子，你会说这些是
uneducated members of cult who are just saying what they want to believe. Yeah. Well, but you don't have to be 20th century to say that, because that's what the priest is saying. That's what Celsus is saying. And into the 20th century, you do have all kinds of people as the kind of tide of skepticism rises. So you have ever more theory. So you have D.H lawrence wrote a story about in which jesus isn't dead and he kind of wakes up and he kind of totters off right and again this is this is a theory that is dearly held by the ahmadis who are a strain of it strain of muslims in particularly in uh kashmir who say that jesus went to kashmir and is buried there you can see his
邪教中不受教育的成员，他们只是在说他们愿意相信的话。是的。嗯，其实你不需要生活在20th世纪才能这么说，因为祭司就是这么说的，刻尔苏斯也是这么说的。到了20th世纪，随着怀疑主义浪潮的涌起，确实出现了各种各样的人。所以你有越来越多的理论。比如D.H.劳伦斯写过一个故事，其中耶稣没有死，他醒来后一瘸一拐地走开了，对，同样的，这也是艾哈迈迪派深信不疑的一个理论，艾哈迈迪派是穆斯林的一个分支，特别是在克什米尔地区，他们说耶稣去了克什米尔并被埋葬在那里，你可以看到他的
tomb japanese claim that that jesus traveled all the way to japan so that's another theory who say that Jesus went to Kashmir and is buried there. You can see his tomb. Japanese claim that Jesus traveled all the way to Japan. So that's another theory. Another very popular theory that developed in the 60s, well, actually before the 60s, it's kind of the golden bow and all that kind of stuff in the Victorian period. But it takes on a particularly distinctive form in the 60s and 70s is that the whole resurrection story, the whole existence of Jesus, it's a myth that it's like Osiris rising from the dead, the Egyptian god, or Adonis, who we talked about in our World Cup of Gods with his unfortunate wedding. And the brilliant
陵墓。日本人声称耶稣一路旅行到了日本。所以这是另一个理论。另一个非常流行的理论是在60年代发展起来的——好吧，其实在60年代之前，维多利亚时期的《金枝》以及所有诸如此类的东西就已经有了。但在60年代和70年代，它呈现出了一种非常独特的形态，那就是整个复活的故事，耶稣的整个存在，都是一个神话，就像奥西里斯从死里复活一样，那个埃及神，或者阿多尼斯——我们在众神世界杯中讨论过他那不幸的婚礼。而这个理论在60年代和70年代最辉煌的
formulation of this theory in the 60s and 70s is by a guy who was a very distinguished scholar of the Dead Sea Scrolls called John Marco Allegro, who claimed that it was prompted by the ingestion of magic mushrooms and that this was a cult that took magic mushrooms and that Jesus was actually a magic mushroom. A mushroom? Yeah. That's a very 60s idea, isn't it? It's very, very 60s. So with those series, the idea that it's mythic, that's a very kind of late Victorian idea. It's there in the Golden Bough that people are obsessed by all this kind of stuff. And the idea and the other another theory that also emerged in the 70s that also is very much bread of the age is that jesus was an extraterrestrial so this is bread of eric von daniken right uh the angels who are seen by mary magdalene when jesus has risen
阐述者是一个死海古卷的杰出学者，名叫约翰·马科·阿莱格罗，他声称这是由于摄入魔幻蘑菇引起的，这是一个食用魔幻蘑菇的邪教，而耶稣实际上就是一个魔幻蘑菇。一个蘑菇？是的。这真是一个非常60年代的想法，不是吗？非常非常60年代。所以关于这些理论，认为它是神话的想法，这是一个非常晚期维多利亚时代的想法。它存在于《金枝》中，人们对所有这类事情都着迷。这种想法，以及70年代出现的另一个同样深深打上时代烙印的理论是，耶稣是一个外星人——所以这是埃里希·冯·丹尼肯的产物，对吧，玛丽·抹大拉在耶稣复活时看到的那些天使，
you know they they wear what they're clothed in white they shine this is clearly reflective of a kind of radioactivity uh And in due course, Jesus will ascend to heaven. He's being teleported up to a flying saucer. So we don't know. But I would say, I would say, for whatever reason, probably to do with what Jesus himself had taught before his death. And some strangeness, something weird that happens after it, whether the body gets stolen, whatever. I mean, we don't know. People very very early on think that jesus has risen that he is the messiah and pretty quickly they're coming to the the conclusion you know they're making very very exalted claims for jesus that he's included with god as a kind of recipient of the cultic devotion of early Christians.
你知道的，他们穿着白色的衣服，他们发光，这显然反映了一种放射性。并且在适当的时候，耶稣将升入天国。他被传送到了一艘飞碟上。所以我们不知道。但我会说，我会说，无论出于什么原因，可能与耶稣死前自己所教导的东西有关，以及死后发生的一些奇怪的事情，无论是尸体被盗，还是其他什么。我的意思是，我们不知道。人们在非常非常早的时候就认为耶稣已经复活了，他是弥赛亚，而且很快他们就得出了结论，（你知道的）他们对耶稣提出了极高的声称，认为他与上帝同列，作为早期基督徒崇拜的对象。
Because people are not worshipping him during his lifetime. Is that right? They're following him, but they're not. They don't think he's God. If the Gospels can be relied upon, they seem unsure as to who or what he is. They just know that he's something very, well, the special one. But at some basic level, they must know he's the carpenter guy from Nazareth. So, you know, no prophet has honor in his own land this is jesus quotes this so yes i mean maybe people who he's grown up among are less inclined to yeah you know if you pay lip service to all
因为人们在他生前并没有崇拜他。是这样吗？他们跟随他，但他们没有。他们不认为他是上帝。如果福音书是可以信赖的话，他们似乎不确定他是谁或他是什么。他们只知道他是一个非常——好吧，那个特别的人。但在某种基本层面上，他们一定知道他是纳萨雷特那个做木匠的家伙。所以，你知道的，本地先知不受人尊敬，耶稣引用过这个——所以，是的，我的意思是，也许与他一起长大的人不太倾向于——是的，你知道的，如果你对所有
this kind of mad stuff he's coming out if you were playing football with him in the reign of augustus you're less likely to yeah exactly so look at the earliest christian text we have yeah which is probably the first letter that paul writes to the thessalonians in that jesus is hailed by paul as as kyrgios as lord and that's a word that is also applied to god by greek-speaking judeans um he is described as the son of god. Paul is saying that Jesus will come and he will rescue the elect. He will rescue the saved. And this is a tradition that you also get in Mark, who is the earliest gospel, probably, where he says that people will sit. The son of man will come in clouds with power and glory, and he will send the angels out and he will gather up the
这些他抛出的疯狂东西只是敷衍了事的话。如果你在奥古斯都统治时期和他一起踢足球，你就不太可能会——是的，绝对如此。所以看看我们拥有的最早的基督教文本，对吧，这可能是保罗写给帖撒罗尼迦人的第一封信，在那封信中，耶稣被保罗尊为“Kyrios”，即主，这也是说希腊语的犹太人用来称呼上帝的词，呃，他被称为上帝的儿子。保罗说耶稣会来，他会拯救选民。他会拯救得救的人。这也是你在马可福音中能找到的一个传统，马可很可能是最早的福音书，他在书中说人们会坐在一起。人子将在云中带着能力和荣耀降临，他会派遣天使去聚集
elect and and you know it's all going to be tremendous and hurrah so mark doesn't i i can't actually remember what the thinking is on whether mark is familiar with paul i think it probably isn't but if he's not then that that's you know those are clearly traditions you know both of both texts are drawing on the kind of yeah the same traditions so i i think it's all very odd to go back it's it's odd in the way that the quran is odd and that oddness seems to me the kind of the radioactive source of power at the heart of the the you know of the power station because if you go right up to the point where he's crucified nothing about that story is is actually that strange or implausible, is it? Because as we've said, there are other holy men, there are other
选民，然后——你知道的，这一切都会非常了不起，让人欢呼。所以马可并没有——我其实记不清大家的看法了，马可是否熟悉保罗的作品，我想他可能不熟悉，但如果他不熟悉，那么——你知道的，那些显然是传统（这两个文本都在借鉴的那种——对，相同的传统）。所以我认为这一切都很奇怪，回过头来看，这和《古兰经》的奇怪之处一样，这种奇怪之处在我看来就像是发电厂核心的那种放射性动力源，因为如果你一直走到他被钉上十字架的那一刻，那个故事的任何部分其实都没有那么奇怪或难以置信，对吧？因为正如我们所说，还有其他圣人，还有其他
preachers, miracle workers, healers, and so on. And it's as you described in the very first episode, there was that fellow in Gaul who Vitellius executed. So right up to that point, nothing about the story of Jesus of Nazareth is necessarily implausible, unusual. You know, he's just a remarkable character with remarkable teachings. Well, it's all the kind of chucking demons into pigs. Yeah, but presumably if stories had been written about other miracle workers, they would have also had dealings with pigs and whatever. But what is unusual is followers affirm very vigorously that he was resurrected, that he ascended into heaven, and that they spread across the eastern Mediterranean with this story and that it catches on. That is what elevates it, isn't it? It's the resurrection and what follows.
传教士、奇迹创造者、治愈者等等。就像你在第一集里描述的那样，维特利乌斯处决高卢的那个人。所以一直到那个点，拿撒勒人耶稣的故事的任何部分都不一定是不合理的、不寻常的。你知道的，他只是一个有着非凡教导的非凡人物。嗯，这都是把恶魔赶进猪群之类的。是的，但据推测，如果关于其他奇迹制造者的故事被写下来，他们也会与猪或类似的东西打交道。但不寻常的是，他的信徒非常坚定地坚信他复活了，他升入了天国，并且他们带着这个故事传遍了地中海东部，并且它流行开了。正是这一点提升了它，不是吗？是复活以及随之而来的事情。
Yeah, but the resurrection in itself, I think, is insufficient to explain it. Even if you're seeing a risen, you know, there is no other story is told of a Judean rising from the dead. So that in itself is kind of weird and distinctive. But even so, it would be insufficient, I think, because there are quite a lot of stories of people rising from the dead. So in and of itself, I mean, you know, it's obviously a very weird, exceptional thing to happen, but it's not wholly unheard of. I mean, Jesus raises Lazarus from the dead, according to the Gospels. So I think it's three things. I think undoubtedly the resurrection or people believing in the resurrection is a crucial part of it. I think the drama of his death, which in some way Jesus seems to have embraced, he seems to have knowingly gone to his death. And the way in which it is possible for the disciples and the apostles and his followers to frame it and to see it as
是的，但仅就复活本身而言，我认为不足以解释这一切。即使你看到一个复活的——你知道的，没有其他关于犹太人死而复生的故事被讲述过。所以这本身就很奇怪且独特。但即便如此，我认为这还是不够的，因为有很多关于死而复生的故事。所以就其本身而言，我的意思是，（你知道的）这显然是一件非常奇怪、非常罕见的事件，但并非闻所未闻。我的意思是，根据福音书，耶稣曾使拉撒路从死里复活。所以我认为是三件事。我认为毫无疑问，复活或人们对复活的信仰是其中至关重要的一部分。我认为他死亡的戏剧性，耶稣在某种程度上似乎接受了这一点，他似乎是有意识地走向死亡。以及门徒、使徒和他的追随者如何能够构建它，并将其视为
the expression of prophecies that are in Judean scripture that had never been previously been understood in that light, that actually God will manifest himself through humiliation and death. I mean, that's the kind of the blinding insight that Paul, for instance, clearly has. It's something that he sees, he recognizes having always been there in Judean scripture and Jesus' death has kind of made it manifest. But neither of those things I think would happen had Jesus himself not been the most remarkable teacher, because I think it's the stickability of his sayings, of his teachings. So Nietzsche brilliantly described Jesus as having had a flair for language that today would see him sent to Siberia. Right. It's the fact that Jesus is preaching something very odd, unsettling, disturbing, and yet attractive to his listeners, and that he preaches it in a way that sticks in the mind.
犹太圣经中从未被那样理解过的预言的表达，即上帝实际上将通过羞辱和死亡来彰显自己。我的意思是，这就是保罗等人显然拥有的那种醍醐灌顶的洞察力。这是他所看到、他所认识到的，一直存在于犹太圣经中，而耶稣的死让它显现出来了。但在我看来，如果没有耶稣本人成为最杰出的教师，这两件事都不会发生，因为我认为这是他的言论、他的教导的持久力。所以尼采曾精彩地形容耶稣拥有某种对语言的直觉，这种直觉在今天会把他送往西伯利亚。对。事实是，耶稣宣扬的东西非常奇怪、不安、令人不安，然而对他的听众却很有吸引力，并且他宣扬它的方式能让人铭记在心。
You don't have to believe everything in the Gospels is literally the words of Jesus, is literally gospel. I think to accept that this kind of body of sayings is so consistent, it's so coherent, it's so distinctive, that it's very hard to explain where they would have come from, if not from a remarkable figure. And Christians see Jesus, obviously, as having been a remarkable figure. And so the fact that Jesus was a remarkable figure, and that this is what prompted Christians to write about him seems to me the likeliest explanation for it. That's a hunch derived from my reading of the material. There are, of course, a whole range of other explanations that would be possible. And so to an extent, that is my formulation of a position that ultimately I'm agnostic about. So just on other explanations, your explanation focuses very much on the personality of Jesus.
你不需要相信福音书中的每一件事都是耶稣的字面原话，都是字面上的真理。我认为要接受这一事实：这套言论是如此一致，如此连贯，如此独特，以至于如果它们不是来自一个非凡的人物，很难解释它们是从哪里来的。基督徒显然将耶稣视为一个非凡的人物。因此，耶稣是一个非凡的人物，正是这一点促使基督徒书写关于他的内容，在我看来，这是对此最合理的解释。这是我从阅读材料中得出的直觉。当然，还存在一系列其他的解释。所以在某种程度上，这就是我阐述的一个立场，对此我最终是不可知论的。关于其他的解释，你的解释非常侧重于耶稣的个性。
Is there another explanation which would be focused more on the context, which would be there is not on supply, as it were, but on demand, that there is a particular context in the first century AD in which people are craved for whatever reason? I don't know, economic, political. People are craving this. And so they almost create it. Is that plausible? I don't think so. Because this isn't a particularly troubled or difficult period for people in the Eastern Mediterranean? Not particularly, no. The idea that Palestine was heaving with kind of revolutionary instincts is one that's been very popular, but I think is not true. We did two episodes on the Judean revolt. I think it was basically,
有没有另一种解释会更多地关注背景，也就是说，不是供给侧，而是需求侧，即公元一世纪存在一个特定的背景，无论出于什么原因，人们都对此充满渴望？我不知道，经济的、政治的。人们渴望这个。所以他们几乎是凭空创造了它。这合理吗？我不这么认为。因为对于地中海东部的人民来说，这是一个特别动荡或艰难的时期吗？并不是特别艰难，没有。巴勒斯坦充斥着革命冲动的想法曾非常流行，但我认为那不是真的。我们做了两集关于犹太起义的节目。我认为它基本上是，
it was kind of accident. It was contingency that prompted it. And so then we read back to it. But, you know, as I say, right at the beginning, there are people who are making, you know, Roman rule is pretty brutal. Conditions are pretty tough. There are people who are claiming divine sanction for claims for a kingship, but I think, you know, none of the others inspired what Jesus inspired. So there's something about Jesus. That's what you're basically,
它是一种偶然。是偶然性引发了它。所以我们随后又回溯解释它。但是，正如我所说，就在一开始，就有人在宣称——罗马统治相当残酷。条件相当艰苦。有人在为对王权的声称寻求神圣的庇护，但我认为，你知道的，没有其他人能激发耶稣所激发出的一切。所以耶稣身上有某种特质。这就是你基本上要说的，
there is something special. I mean, I think that you could, and indeed I have explain, explain the 2000 years of Western, you know, of history as attempts to answer who Jesus was. Christians have done it and post-Christians have done it. It's the question of who he was. And by that, I mean more than, you know, was he a real person, but was he, you know, what exactly was he? I think this is not a back projected strangeness. I think the strangeness
有某种特别之处。我的意思是，我认为你可以——事实上我也已经这样解释了——将西方两千年的历史解释为试图回答耶稣是谁的尝试。基督徒做到了，后基督徒也做到了。这是一个关于他是谁的问题。我的意思是，这不仅仅是“他是一个真实的人吗”，而是“他究竟是什么？”我认为这不是一种后投射出来的奇怪感。我认为这种奇怪感
was hardwired into him. And you don't have to be a Christian to accept that because Nietzsche said Jesus is the strangest person who ever lived. You mentioned Occam's razor before. I mean, if you're using Occam's razor, the simplest explanation is that Jesus was the son of God. I mean, historians wouldn't make, well, do historians make that claim? Do other historians who would end their book by saying? No, they don't. Because, you know, Stephen Jay Gould said that they're a rival magisteria, the magisteria of science and of religion. And I guess historians would capture it in similar terms that, you know, that history and religion are rival magisteria. Basically, you know, so Gibbon
是深深植根于他体内的。你不需要成为一个基督徒去接受这一点，因为尼采说过耶稣是有史以来最奇怪的人。你之前提到了奥卡姆剃刀。我的意思是，如果你使用奥卡姆剃刀，最简单的解释就是耶稣是上帝的儿子。我的意思是，历史学家不会做出——好吧，历史学家会做出那种断言吗？会有其他历史学家在他们的书结尾时说吗？不，他们不会。因为，你知道的，史蒂芬·杰伊·古尔德说过，它们是互不相容的两个领域，科学领域和宗教领域。我想历史学家会用类似的术语来概括，你知道的，历史和宗教是互不相容的领域。基本上，你知道的，吉本
in the, back in the 18th century you know he he articulated this very well he said the theologian may indulge the pleasing task of describing religion as she descended from heaven a raid in her native purity a more melancholy duty is imposed on the historian i mean i think that historians do not accept supernatural explanations they may be christian i mean there's nothing nothing to stop a historian being a Christian or believing in the supernatural. But I think when they come to write history, by and large, they don't adduce supernatural explanations. And I don't think that you need supernatural explanations to explain Jesus and the emergence of Christianity. But having said that, I think there are lots of reasons why one might choose not to believe in God, and specifically perhaps not believe in the
在18th世纪时，你知道的，他非常清楚地表达了这一点，他说：“神学家可以沉溺于这样一种令人愉悦的任务：将宗教描述为从天而降，身披纯洁原生之袍；而历史学家则被赋予了一项更加忧郁的职责。”我的意思是，我认为历史学家不接受超自然的解释。他们可能是基督徒，我的意思是，没有什么能阻止一个历史学家成为基督徒或相信超自然现象。但我认为当他们开始书写历史时，大体上，他们不会引用超自然的解释。而且我认为你不需要超自然解释来解释耶稣和基督教的崛起。话虽如此，我认为有很多理由可以选择不相信上帝，特别是可能不相信
Christian understanding of God. But I would say that the inadequacy of the New Testament as source would not be one of them that I would adduce. So I've come to this from studying both the origins of Islam and from studying classical sources. And the closer up I get to them, the more, you know, I'm pretty impressed by actually how much evidence there is for Jesus. Okay. Well, Tom, we've been talking for a long time now about this. And actually, I kind of feel like we've only scratched the surface, don't you? As you said, there are people who've given up, you know, this and actually i kind of feel like we've only scratched the surface don't you i mean i mean this
基督教对上帝的理解。但我会说，新约作为资料的不足并不是我会提出的理由之一。所以我研究这些资料，既源于对伊斯兰教起源的研究，也源于对古典文献的研究。而且我越是深入了解它们，你知道的，我对实际上存在多少关于耶稣的证据感到相当震撼。好吧，汤姆，我们已经谈了很长时间了。实际上，我觉得我们才刚触及皮毛，你不觉得吗？正如你所说，有些人已经放弃了，你知道的，这实际上我觉得我们才刚触及皮毛，你不觉得吗？我的意思是，我的意思是
as you said there are people who've given up you know their entire working life to studying a single passage or a single line from the bible so um i really do feel like uh there's so much more to be said by people who are much more well certainly much better versed in this than i am and perhaps even better versed than you dare i I say it. Oh, definitely. I mean, you know, people study it for their entire career, great professors, great, I mean, of course. I mean, we are literally only scratching the surface. Is it the biggest story in history, do you think? Because it's so foundational for our entire understanding
正如你所说，有些人一辈子的工作时间都用来研究圣经中的一个段落或一行文字，所以嗯，我真的觉得，嗯，那些比我更有经验、当然也精通得多的人，甚至可能比你还要精通的人，还有很多话要说，我敢这么说吗？哦，当然。我是说，你知道的，人们用整个职业生涯来研究它，伟大的教授们，伟大的，我的意思是，当然。我的意思是，我们真的只是触及了皮毛。你认为这是历史上最大的故事吗？因为它对我们整个理解是如此基础
of ourselves and the world, our culture, our literature, our assumptions, our moral landscape landscape all these kinds of things so i i remember years when i was at school we were doing roman history and a teacher saying what was the most significant event in the lifetime of augustus and so you know battle of actium or whatever and, of course, it's the birth of Jesus. And he was saying that not as a Christian, but because that is the most significant event. What happens with the lifetime of Jesus, had Jesus not existed,
关于我们自己和世界、我们的文化、我们的文学、我们的假设、我们的道德景观，所有这些事情，所以我记得多年前我在上学时，我们在学罗马历史，一位老师问奥古斯都一生中最重大的事件是什么，所以你知道，亚克兴战役之类的，当然，那就是耶稣的诞生。他这么说不是作为一个基督徒，而是因为那是具有最重大意义的事件。如果耶稣没有存在过，在耶稣的一生中会发生什么，
I think the world would be unfathomably different. Right. Shall I end with a Bible reading? Oh, Tom, I'd love that. I really would. I'm going to end with the very last verse of the Gospel of St. John. And there are also many other things which Jesus did, the which, if they should be written every one,
我认为世界将会大不相同。好的。我该用一段圣经朗读来结束吗？哦，汤姆，我太愿意了。我真的很想。我将以《圣经·约翰福音》的最后一节来结束。耶稣所行的事还有许多，若是一一的都写出来，
I suppose that even the world itself could not contain the books that should be written. And that would be a problem for us, wouldn't it? It certainly would. Yes, it is. We've finished the podcast. Yeah. And that's it. Amen.
我想，就是世界也容纳不下所写的书。那对我们来说会是一个问题，对吧？当然会的。是的，就是这样。我们播客做完了。嗯。就这样。阿门。
Jolly good. Bye-bye, everybody. Bye finished the podcast. Yeah. And that's it. Amen. Jolly good. Bye-bye everybody. Bye-bye. Happy Christmas. Happy Christmas. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access,
太好了。大家再见。再见，播客做完了。嗯。就这样。阿门。太好了。大家再见。再见。圣诞快乐。圣诞快乐。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、抢先收听、
ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。这是你们每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料的固定栏目，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，告诉大家这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com 本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。